okay am i hot well no that's the wrong
question it is my mic hot yeah I guess
it is welcome folks you're probably a
little bit tired of looking at code and
things like that let's use the other
side of your brain a little bit
in this session those of you don't know
me I started writing code in the 1970s
if you can believe that before many of
you were born and I have a lifelong
interest in science going all the way
back to as a kid and and through present
day and about twelve years ago I started
doing a lot more work in UX design I'm
still code but I actually design
software more than I write code these
days now I look at design through the
lens of science because of my experience
and I find that most designers don't
really look at it that way most
designers have an intuitive approach to
design and siano developers you don't go
for that touchy-feely intuitive stuff do
you know you have to have reasons for
things and the reasons are typically
based in the science of the visual and
cognitive systems that all human beings
shared and this session is about that
science and explaining some of the
design principles that come out of that
some of those tech mistakes that
developers somehow sometimes make ways
to avoid those mistakes better options
so I hope you'll enjoy this session as a
little bit of a counterpoint to some of
the other things that you've seen one of
the reasons this is important is that
people's expectations are rising I was
at the reconstructed Globe Theater
yesterday called an uber to take me back
to my hotel
beautiful piece of software the most of
the value of the company uber is in that
app right there and because of
experience with things like that
people's expectations have gone up how
many of you have a screen that looks
more or less like this somewhere in your
app today yeah see and this is it this
isn't good enough anymore and so to do
better you need to understand what your
users see that's the foundation of
giving them better design you can talk
about a/b testing why is a better than
being
why did they prefer B over a in some
circumstances
is there a C out there that's better
well design principles inform us on that
and you can get better designs faster if
you understand some of those principles
now I'm gonna bring the next thing up
but first I need to ask a question to
see whether I need to actually show this
30-second video how many of you have
seen a video where there are two teams
passing basketballs around how many of
you have not seen that video oh gosh
that's the overwhelming majority would
those who have seen it indulge me a
little bit yeah but you must be quiet
and not give away the answer to the
question that I'm gonna ask them okay so
let's show that video then once with
this I've got it I think right here I do
okay let's make this fullscreen and play
how many passes does the team in white
make
how many pastors did you see 13 there's
a little bit of ambiguity but most
people see 13 now for those of you had
never seen this video my next question
is actually the most important was there
anything in that video that you saw that
was unexpected that you that didn't seem
to be in place with the rest of the
video anybody yeah a monkey
walked across who saw a monkey who saw
nothing like that whatsoever well it
wasn't really a monkey but let's play
the rest of it he's 13 but did you see
the moonwalking bear
[Music]
I've been in groups of developers I've
been showing that video for a long time
I was at micron technologies if you know
them 15 people in the room not a single
one saw the moonwalking bear so if you
didn't see it don't feel as though you
are defective in some way it has to do
with the way your visual system works
and I'm gonna explain a little bit about
that but first I'll give you another
quick test now I mean now you know
you're supposed to be looking more
attentively and yet and yet you'll still
struggle in this test I'm gonna show
three slides with drawings of household
tools that you might find in your house
or workshop I would like you to tell me
how many of those slides contain a
hammer I'm only going to leave the
slides up for a couple three seconds
each are you ready
how many hammers most people seem to the
hammers without too much trouble but
then um how many pairs of pliers any
pairs of scissors
I mean wrenches you see you think you
see all of the screens that you look at
and you think your users do too but they
don't really the human visual system
simply does not work that way
you only have a small portion of high
resolution the part of the retina that
gives you that is called the fovea if
you want to see the amount of high
resolution that you have hold a pound
coin out at arm's length and that's the
approximate amount of high resolution
you have a design principle is something
that describes how users interact with
design things including computer
software based on the way their brains
and visual systems work
you can't just train people out of it
it's a part of our biology and that
inattentional blindness is one of the
design principles we're going to look at
several Gestalt principles are up next
we're going to look at color and hue how
we perceive that to signal information
we're going to look at other experience
based visual things such as archetypes
and familiarity that combine visual and
cognition but then attentional blindness
is the first one because I demonstrated
to you that it exists in you and that's
a way of helping you understand it
exists in just about everybody so one of
the things that means is your eyes are
constantly darting around to pick out
the part of the visual field that's
important right now and as you saw that
tendency is based on what you're trying
to do the task at hand and what you
expect to see you expected to see
hammers you found them
you didn't expect to see scissors so you
filtered them right out you didn't
expect to see a moonwalking bear you
filtered it right out that's the way the
visual system works and that's one of
the reasons for example that we don't
want crowded screens let's go back to
this show this a few moments ago
as an example the kind of screens that
exist in many apps today let me black it
out there were some demographic
information in the upper left how many
of you noticed who it was for Sherlock
Holmes I didn't give you any priming so
you didn't really look at that screen
did you only a few people happen to
notice that well in fact even if you
look for something in particular what
you really get this is a simulation that
the part that you're looking at the
fovea zeroes in on a small part of the
screen that you're looking at the rest
of it you don't really see it and I've
simulated that with some blur here and
that means that you didn't notice
something about that particular screen
that I'm going to show you now I have by
the way I have several demos here they
are written in WPF for desktops so if
you if you are interested in that
technology and you'd like to get these
demonstrations I'm happy to give them to
you Ellie did you do you think do I need
to I guess I mean I think I need to
start this over I was fooling around
doing something
okay so here is that screen and I've
made it so that I can drag this thing
around and again that's about the area
you actually see closely what you
probably did not notice is that the
further to the right you get the more
the screen turns into complete gibberish
anybody notice that as you were looking
at it alright let's let's take a look
and see for example if you start to move
over to here
what's a Fuss Tumut what's in what's a
frame ulam blastic inc fisher table that
almost sounds reasonable
what's a Dingle plump but a rest are
possible you say you didn't you didn't
really see those things so when your
users tell you they want dry dead
strings know that rope they really don't
what they want are well-designed Springs
that give them access to the information
they need when they have a crowd to the
screen if they don't need that some of
the things that are on there they just
filter it out in fact it kind of makes
it more difficult for the fovea to zero
in on what they need a screen with it's
looser more white space with groups of
things they might be interested in will
work cognitively and visually far better
so why do users beg for crowded screens
if that if you are convinced about what
I just said well that's because they
don't trust you they assume if you don't
put the information on the first screen
they see that you will hide it somewhere
and they'll never find it and they
assume that because they've had
experience with people doing just that
to them developers that don't understand
their job and don't understand what
pieces of information they really need
to see so it's a much higher level of
responsibility to give them an uncrowded
screen it means you have to understand
their job and more about how they use
information but the result is vastly
improved productivity lower training and
things like that
and the patterns for dealing with too
much information are well established
you've got one of them on your
smartphone right now you look at the
Settings app for a typical phone this is
for iPhone and first of all information
is categorized and some kind of
hierarchy to make it easier to find but
that simply doesn't work in all cases
does it especially when you start
running into hundreds of different
things people might do or hundreds of
pieces of information so what do they do
about that they put a search capability
to zero in on the things that people are
interested in that's one of several
patterns for dealing with lots of
information you should understand those
patterns and be able to give you users
points that aren't nearly so crowded so
now we know what the phobia looks at
what's the rest of the vision for well
peripheral vision really doesn't do that
much for you in software in real world
it does it alerts you to dangers and
things we see a little bit of that in
software when we jiggle an error message
or something because movement in the
periphery draws people's attention to it
so we can get their attention by
vibrating things something a little bit
animating it don't do that too much it
gets to be annoying do it just a little
bit and then stop as you saw what users
see is heavily influenced about what
they expect to see let me give you an
example from my own personal experience
in real life and
by the way I often do real-life examples
to drive the point home because design
is everywhere and the principles in the
real world apply to your software in
most cases too so let's ask a question
to start with first of all I'm going to
the ground floor elevator in a parking
garage
how many elevator buttons do I expect to
expect to see just one going up I can't
go down there's there's no down ok what
is the shape of a typical elevator
button round by far the most common so I
walk into this parking garage toward the
elevator and this is what I see I see a
round thing that looks like a button and
I'll walk right up to it and press it
and then the guy comes on and says yes
this is security because I'm thinking
about other things you see and my eyes
just see that little thing that's a and
just filters out that stuff on the side
over there because that's what I press
and he was used to this people must do
this a dozen times a day he sounded
bored certainly he certainly didn't
think it was an emergency that I'd press
the call button and you look over the
full picture and you see that there is
the elevator button it doesn't really
stand out or anything so I press the
wrong one that is unambiguous evidence
of bad design and it illustrates some of
these design principle design principles
for example we're gonna talk a little
bit about archetypes later an archetype
is an expected form the most common
elevator buttons that you see around
that's an example of an archetype this
could be fixed in a number of ways they
could color this thing red I don't
expect elevator buttons I press to be
red they could put a little flap over it
so that I had the lift of the flap to
press it I don't expect all of either
buttons to have flaps
that would have jerked my mind back to
all this is not an elevator button and I
would have looked and found the one to
the side of it
other examples of expectation setting
how people see things there's a concept
called framing they've done research on
this they lead people through a series
of model
kitchens and they pretended it was some
kind of marketing research they did
about ten of them in two of the kitchens
they left out the stove when people got
to the end and they were asked almost
everyone assured the researchers that
they saw a stove in every kitchen they
filled in the stove that wasn't there
because that was what they expected a
kitchen to be like they expected a
kitchen to have a stove in it so
people's visual perception is extremely
sensitive to what they expect even to
the point that they will imagine things
that aren't even there if Thanks but if
they expect them to be there
people's perceptions and actions are
also subject to something called
habituation they get in the groove in
the habit of doing something let me show
you a spoofed up software example I have
two that see where is it it's another
one of these that one don't wait but the
example for that areas I have quite
moved all my examples in that one
central place yet but I'm going to do
that so imagine you're in this typical
situation of you're leading your users
through some steps and you know you get
down and you get ready to do you do some
things you press the next button and you
go over to the next screen do some
things press the next button do some
things press the next button do some
things press the button you just click
the back button you see because the
person designing the screens me stupidly
or viciously changed the back end next
buttons and you think no developer would
ever do that
that's stupid
I give you American Airlines
this was a screen I captured trying to
get a flight
oh it's been about three years enacting
this this example of doing things this
way of doing things was up there for 18
months because I look to see let me set
it for you I've got this is the fourth
screen
you bought a flight online you know what
the story is you pick your date you do
this you do that fill in your name all
the bureaucratic stuff this is the
fourth screen and every other screen has
had a button in the lower right hand
corner which was basically the continue
button so I finished filling out this
screen scroll to the bottom and press
the button in the lower right and I
don't even read it because what do I
expect there to be that's to continue
right well here's what what really what
really happens is if you don't fill in
the credit card information then it
doesn't show you a continue button they
decided that buttons that that you
couldn't press should not be shown which
seems reasonable and then they decided
well our buttons for cosmetic effect are
going to be right aligned those two
things sound completely reasonable until
you put them together and then you get
this so that once I filled in all the
credit card information it changed to
this American Airlines was losing money
every day their app worked this way
because some percentage of people would
hit that start over button and go well
screw this I'm going to Delta I'm going
to British Airways somebody actually
flew over on British Airways from
Nashville they have a direct flight here
now so understand that part of the
problem with that was the expectation of
where the button was but also part of
the problem was that shape and color
signal better than text I didn't even
bother to read the start over reading
takes effort it takes a lot more
cognitive effort than seeing shapes and
colors and and your users in many cases
probably are not as fast a reader as you
are and they don't understand a lot of
the words you use it's just jargon to
them so let's let's see
here this is the sort of screen that
I've fudged up but is I hope I'm an
example of the kind of thing you might
put up to alert somebody to a security
condition this sounds perfectly
reasonable to you but this is how your
users perceive it
they don't know the words all they know
is you've put up a step that keeps them
from doing what it is they want to do
and if you say clicking this will let
you do what you want then they're going
to click it the rest of it is irrelevant
to them so don't put up a lot of text
like that instead use color and shape to
put meaning into your apps this is an
app we did for a company in Minnesota in
the USA they have a package that helps
manage propane distribution well if
you're in the propane business these two
tanks make perfect sense to you based on
your experience a propane tank is kind
of Tylenol shaped capsule shaped and the
color of propane is like green fuel oil
kerosene tanks have a different shape
more like an elongated cylinder and
their fuel is red so you need no
training or anything to understand what
the type of the tanker is and how full
it is because we've given that
visualization to you you instantly know
the information the critical information
you need to know about that particular
customer's particular tank because some
people have more than one let's give a
stool test here let's look at the third
one over there and you see there's
there's like little circles emitting
from the top of it what do you suppose
that means come on you're smart people
somebody will get it it's it's a
wireless gage so that tank is equipped
with a means to constantly transmit how
much fuel that it's got in it and that's
a much better way of doing it than
putting some check box that says has
Wireless gauge checked or unchecked
which is what unfortunately quite a lot
of developers would do today probably in
a cell of a data grid because the most
common design I see in apps today is
what's normally called the wall of data
grids design and as you move forward
people's expectations to get better you
need to be able to do better with things
like this also notice some some one
the use of shape along the bottom down
there that's the most recent
interactions with that customer and
interaction when the customer might be
several things might be a service call
might be a delivery might be payment of
a bill which one on the bottom do you
suppose denotes a service call I'm sorry
the first one how could you know that I
haven't trained you on this app because
in the background is a wrench and it's
it's dim enough that it doesn't
interfere with reading the text at all
but it is perceptible enough to guide
the eye to the thing that somebody's
looking for so using shape and color can
be powerful indicators there are some
others on here and by the way there's a
smiley face in the upper left so this is
a good customer or well I'm sorry a
happy customer and then there's a CEO D
over on the left that's America and
Mehra that he's collect on delivery do
you use that the same phrase used here
and it's red because you want to know if
somebody doesn't pay their bills I guess
they're happy because they haven't had
to pay for their their gas the visual
system is also very influenced by
context for example I'm going to show
you a slide and and I'm gonna prime you
for it but tell you that it's a campus
map and you'll see roads and buildings
you ready okay so you see roads and
buildings but now what if I tell you
there's a word in the buildings did you
feel your visual systems shift based on
what you were looking for and and
expecting that's an example of a
principle called figure-ground you've
probably seen this famous diagram right
here what do you see two faces of a's
vaz that's yeah and now that you know
that they're both there you can switch
between them that again is an attribute
of the way the visual system works it
decides that certain portions of the
visual field are important and others
are not important and it focuses and on
the part that it considers important the
group the foreground and then filters
out the rest the
or background and you go what does this
have to do with software well and one of
our first modern apps that we wrote back
in 2008 had a data entry screen that
looked like this and you can see that
it's it's kind of called out subtly
against the background of the the shell
with when in which it sits but now if
you want to do an address that's an
overlay that's a pop-up so that looks
like this and we animated it actually so
that the I don't if you notice the what
was previously the ground right here
shrinks when you go to here and we
animated that and it has a great cast
over it you can't click on it either so
now we have told the visual system you
have a new foreground that you need to
focus on but we preserve the context
here's where you were and here's where
you're going back to so we keep the
context but we guide the user's
attention into the thing they need to
work on and actually this became a
fairly popular way of doing things on
the web for a while some places still do
it I when I first did this presentation
about a year ago Twitter was doing this
with a little bit darker background than
ours
however just knowing that a design
principle exists doesn't necessarily
mean you understand how to use it right
let me give you a great example that a
lot of you probably experienced how many
of you used Visual Studio 2012 at some
point yeah you remember the famous
toolbar up at the top had no color
whatsoever on it why did they do that
well first of all understand that unlike
most of the community people at
Microsoft are very very code centric
they think in terms of code so they said
well figure-ground we need to draw
people's attention to the most important
part and to them what's the most
important part code so the code window
became at the foreground and they said
we'll just do emphasize everything else
to make it really easy to use the code
window the problem they didn't
understand is that what you need to be
interested in shifts it's not static you
saw the example I just had where the
foreground needed to shift to a
different view
if they've made it so that when you put
the mouse over it it lit up then that
thing would have been fine but as it is
I was doing a session about six months
after this was released and I did the
uncomment button and one guy in the
audience said come looking for that
button for six months it was that hard
to see it and of course they've changed
it since then the bottom is is a more is
the more recent version I think that's
2017 by the way I still think this could
be dramatically improved but it's not as
bad as it was
you can also be primed by past
experience as you've saw the elevator
example was a good example of that I'm
going to show you another elevator
example and I want you to take a look at
it with the following in mind to see if
there's anything about this elevator
panel that you find worth calling out to
someone if you got on the elevator just
look at something when you have
something put your hand up so that I'll
see when most of the audience's found
something mother away there are multiple
things you might find and then I'm going
to talk about the one that I found and
why you ready okay what do you see here
that you might mention to a companion
when you got on the elevator now don't
say it don't say it just put your hand
up when you have something come on I'll
get a few more that's not too bad what
did you see there is no number 13 how
many of you saw that as the first thing
you noticed yes because see your
developers you had that analytical
portion of your brain working eight
hours a day in your office or cubicle so
immediately you look at this and went
there is a missing number in the
sequence between 12 and 14
okay but that's not why I took this
picture it is true what else did you see
the labels look like buttons the
placards look like buttons and we know
that that's a problem because of this
that's what I saw and got my camera now
by the way there's lots of this is a
trainwreck of bad design so I'm not
gonna go into deep analysis of all the
things that are wrong but that's the
first thing I notice unambiguous
evidence of bad design because people
are getting on the elevator
seeing that placard thinking it's a
button and hurting their finger pressing
it many times a day and think about this
when they do that they've already been
up to their room once they're now on the
elevator for at least the second time
and they're still making the mistake
we're gonna come back this elevator
panel and point on another problem in a
few minutes but that is an example of
you see what you're looking for and
remember that these principles kind of
work in concert why don't I see the
button right next to the G well we saw
that didn't we that's the way our visual
system works
it sees small chunks at a time by the
way this is not the only elevator to
exhibit this problem I've made a hobby
of collecting them this one is in Las
Vegas and at a very upscale hotel by the
way and I got on it and the guy the guy
standing by the panel said what what for
you on I said 25 and he pressed the
button for 24 and he said oh I'm sorry
don't worry don't worry about it let me
explain to you the design of elevator
no you you want things to be clear you
want things to stand out in such a way
that people want to have any trouble
notice for example it's another example
of the fuel tanks when they get low
we put 0% we make that big but notice
that there's still a little bit of
propane in the tank so to speak
now see my nine point of view when I
wrote this control for the client was
when it was zero
there was nothing but your experience in
that industry tells you now that tanks
never really empty it gets so low that
it can't get propane through but there's
still some propane in the bottom of the
tank so our visualization reflected that
yeah I think I think I did what I was
gonna do here a few moments ago so I'm
gonna go on other ways that that design
principles affected the way you and your
users see things including computer
screens let me show you a sign in a
hotel in Texas I got off the old vet
about 11 o'clock one night and I was
tired bags etc and I see this sign I'm
in room 207 so I see that and I tried
off to the left
get two doors down and realize oh I'm
going the wrong way
go back and look at the entire sign
which looks like this now when I took
this picture and put it in my
presentation the next day my design
training one of the people in the
audience who come in from out of town
said I did exactly the same thing why
were we both misled well the problem
here is that our mind our visual system
automatically groups things based on how
close they are to each other that's
called the gestalt proximity principle
so if I look at 201 2 2 2 3 that's the
range of my room which one of the arrows
is closest to it the one below this sign
could be vastly improved by doing
nothing more
they're moving the arrows down about two
inches five centimeters each and you
think oh well software people don't do
silly things like that
I'll give you Amazon and which I'm on
their specials of the day page one day a
few years back and I see this 128
gigabit gigabyte USB man that's you know
I'm on the road a lot that sounds great
to me
only thirty $29.99 good price at the
time so I checked the box below it and
then hit the thing to put things in the
in the shopping cart go over to the
shopping cart and that's not there but
there's a random item that is that I
didn't think I picked have you spotted
what the problem is the upper check box
is for this but there's no real visual
indication of that and it's further away
from the item then this is away from the
text so it was a natural mistake again
they're losing money every time they do
that Gestalt principles were studied by
German scientist about a century ago and
they looked into how the human visual
system tries to see the world in terms
of structure and relationships so there
are several principles of design that
come from that called Gestalt principles
and one of them is proximity as you just
saw and the reason that they they work
the way they do is that the human visual
system actually goes through several
stages in perceiving something the first
stage happens in the retina itself the
retina is optimized to boost certain
signals like edges and dampen others so
there's one stage of visual processing
those on the retina you can't really do
anything about that one it's just
automatic Stage two is automatic - it
turns out that we can do some alteration
butBut but the first cut of what you see
is in what's called pre-attentive
processing small fraction of a second
and that is unconscious at that point
you assemble the things in your visual
field into shapes and groups so when I
saw that sign I assembled the group of
this is my room range and this is the
air my
did that automatically and then an
attention processing we use experience
to layer on top of that to maybe alter
the results of stage two we know what it
is or we realize that we didn't that we
were wrong about our interpretation so
we go back and use cognitive efforts to
reinterpret you see that son from from
my hotel room I figured it out so in
that respect the son maker probably
thought he did his job but I had to
expend additional cognitive effort to do
it at a time that I was tired and if you
do that consistently with your software
you'll end up with some very frustrated
and unproductive users your style
principles do come from that stage too
and it's unconscious with the ability to
override it if you need to let's take a
look at Gestalt proximity and a little
bit a little bit more detail first of
all if you put things together that
aren't appropriate in some fashion there
are problems with that because people
have to number one reinterpret the
results but number two if you put
something too close to something else
then that raises the the risk of picking
the wrong thing by mistake I was working
with a piece of software a product that
had the equivalent of code behind and
this is the button above which you would
go edit the code behind a lot of code
behind was automatically generated for
you what this button did was wipe out
your code behind without giving you any
sort of warning that was going to do
that
that's bad design number one you
shouldn't have a button that throws away
hours of work without telling you but
secondly notice how close it is to the
edit button I didn't mean to hit it I
was just in a hurry and went for the
edit button and just to happen to be a
little bit too far to the right so
proximity also helps prevent errors the
iconography is awful too that what about
that chain link says I'm gonna delete
your code
and back to the elevator again one of
the things that's wrong there is that
the proximity principle is not respected
one of the reasons you have trouble
finding which floor that a button goes
to is that buttons are equidistant
between two pockets you have to look at
the entire row to figure out what button
goes with what placard and again that's
possible but it requires extra cognitive
effort so for example you know it
those buttons have Braille on them by
the way I'm not sure how much good it
does because if you're a blind person
you get on there you find four well
which button do you press I didn't know
when to get off now remember this works
inside your mind you don't exactly
control it because it's it's pretty
conscious let me show you I'm gonna show
you a couple of slides that have four
pointed stars on them and I want you to
immediately perceive whether you see
rows of stars or columns of stars and
just yell the answer out when you see it
okay
rows or columns everybody cell rows
they're rows or columns
almost everybody sees columns here well
that's really interesting because that's
those two are the same size grid of
stars except for the fact that they're
grouped differently there's padding
between elements that helps promote
Gestalt proximity so our eyes
automatically group things because of
the spacing do you see rows or columns
in this one a little more ambiguous most
people see rows and you just saw columns
on it now but what that says is that the
mind also groups things by other
attributes including coloring and things
like that color shape and size are the
big things color and shape more so than
size sizes a weak sort of grouping
attribute so that we can group by color
like this will see rows we can group by
shape most people see rows there too and
those principles bother
have been used in things like charting
software all the time proximity draws
together a particular period but
similarity by color helps us follow a
category over time so Gestalt principles
and use if you violate Gestalt
principles you can help make things
stand out very quickly so for example I
don't have to you don't have to search
if I tell you to find the triangle on
the next slide you don't have to scan
around for it your visual system finds
it automatically and if I tell you to
find the green pointed star same thing
your visual system zeros on it very
quickly and we can use these kinds of
capabilities to help people find the
thing they're looking for let me show
you another one of my little sample
programs okay so here is a bunch of
letters suppose I tell you find the Z in
this bunch of letters well you kind of
have to scan around a whole bunch don't
use anybody found it yet but if I make
it bold how much easier is it to find it
much much easier how about the B have
you found the B here well it might help
if I would shift it over a little bit
from all the others those are the kinds
of signals that our visual system is
tuned to pick up to pick out something
that's of interest and we don't use
those kinds of signals in software very
often as far as I can see in particular
shifting something over to draw
attention to it I see it in some
well-designed apps but I rarely see it
in routine business apps I'm going to
show an example later before we used it
and look for one of our clients
down there
proximity could also be misused or bad
signaling about proximity causes
confusion when I had an Android phone
this was the Southwest app and I won the
boarding pass and I I see the thing up
at the top and G pay I don't want to pay
for anything I've already bought my
ticket do you understand what it's
trying to do it wants to put the image
in the wallet but it's not being clear
about that and furthermore I've saved
two phone ok yeah but is that one button
or is that two buttons that that divider
in the middle makes that distinctly
ambiguous don't do things like that to
confuse your users Gestalt continuity
says that people tend to follow
something a consistent structure until
something interrupts it so you can lead
people's attention to things using
Gestalt continuity or you can make
something stand out by violating and
here for example is supposed to be the
timeline of a truck driver doing things
and it's spoofed data I mean nobody
takes three hour lunches in that
business but notice that there's one of
his daily tasks or appointments that's
off from the others what do you suppose
that offset means I'm sorry
collision yes it overlaps with another
thing that he has to do so that was a
very convenient way to very quickly
signal that and that's an example of
something that number one isn't too hard
to figure out and number two is a very
sticky design once you've figured it out
you're never going to forget it you'll
scan and realize that you've got
something off set and therefore that you
are double-booked
let's go through another example that
combines a lot of these things and
introduces a few new ones I'm going to
put up a set of data records cards for
sports equipment and what I want you to
do is count the number of American
football items that you see I mean I
know you guys don't use those here but
you know what they look like right there
The Oval things alright ok how many
American footballs there were three must
miss point okay but notice that you had
to do quite a bit of scanning around to
find that and as before of course you
know army basketballs that were or
soccer balls because your eyes filtered
those out and I don't need to discuss
that in detail that's just another
example of an intentional blindness so
how do we get around this how do we make
things easier for people to see and
understand well one of the principles I
haven't talked about yet is mapping and
I'm going to get to a couple of other
examples later mapping that design
principle refers to matching things on a
computer interface or some other
interface to the real world object that
is being affected something about the
real world because people intuitively
then will understand the interface based
on their experience in the real world it
will make it better for example we could
make the pieces of sports equipment to
have sizes that correspond to their
real-world sizes you see this doesn't do
that does it a baseball is the same size
as a basketball that cognitively kind of
makes it difficult it's one of the
reasons this thing was hard to interpret
even just to find footballs so why don't
we make the items mapped in some fashion
their size on the screen should be
associated in some fashion with their
size in the real world now tennis balls
and baseballs are smaller and much
easier to pick out
soccer balls are somewhat smaller than
basketballs and we can leverage a lot of
design principles to make displays like
this better mapping was just one example
I picked out we already know for example
things close together or visually
grouped we know that color helps in
grouping let's see let's put that
together and see what we get
suppose we get something like this now
how much easier is that to interpret
then the first thing that you saw now I
don't have to work very hard to three
footballs man hard could that be
and by the way this isn't made to have
beautiful aesthetics or whatever this is
a fudged example simply to illustrate
principles so there are various
principles being used here we're using
size shape color and proximity all to do
groups that's four of the Gestalt
principles all wrapped up in one example
we also should call out information
importance more than we do and we could
have done this back in the 90s and I saw
very many I mean we had a font size for
a visual basic back then and it's gone
its competitors but we just didn't do it
very often
because we weren't tuned into the fact
that size different size can signal
importance of information at the time a
lot of us were coming out of character
based applications where we couldn't
change the design the size all we could
do is affect boldness but color makes
information stand out as well as being
bigger red family colors of course like
extra importance or danger or something
green and blue are more safety and
normal so back to this screen and we see
the the the red calls out the C OD up
there and the green up there tells us
that we're okay so um I'll see what I
want to get yeah I'm going to get
through that al D information importance
yeah if you look across the top there
you'll see some of the most important
things about this customer you can
imagine someone picking up a telephone
and a propane shop talking someone on
the phone what do you want to know about
them well how much morning do they only
once
last time I talked to him how much gas
do they have those are the kinds of
information that we'd be interested in
the moment we find out who that person
is and call them up on our screen we'd
probably also want to know what are the
last few interactions that we've had
with that so we make things bigger to
call them out and we use symbology to
call out the different types of things
that we do I talked about that before
but that is an example of using these
various things to emphasize the
importance of information and this
really isn't that hard to do you can see
here red and green signaling we've got
some red and green signalling up there I
hate the yellow dashed line and I can't
convince the client to remove it or to
change me but the rest of this I'm
pretty much okay with we notice the
positioning up there that high priority
items are lifted up a little bit the
ones that aren't so important to have
neutral backgrounds so all of those
things color and size are very useful in
helping people see the information they
need very quickly because they're
leveraging what's going on in the visual
system it doesn't require cognitive
effort you put a data grid in somebody
they have to interpret a lot of sex
text and numbers they have to use more
cognitive effort to get the information
out of the grid that they that they're
looking for whereas if you visualize it
in such a way that they can leverage the
visual system the visual systems like
the brains GPU in a sense it's optimized
for something different than the
cognitive reading portion and it's more
efficient because it has a much longer
evolutionary history visual systems go
back to our noun alien ancestors and
even before whereas how many species
know how to read that's a comparatively
recent evolutionary development we've
seen that users prompt about goals
usually when that go to yourself where
they got some goal in mind and they look
for things related to the goal and
filter everything else out so you should
understand their goal make it easy to to
find the things that
what to uh to do that are related to
that go get the information that they
need that means before you design a view
in any technology at all you should
understand what are the two or three
most common actions they take on that
view you should know their job well
enough to know that and you should know
the four or five six most important
pieces of information they need to
accomplish their goal now this is loose
sometimes it's sometimes there's only
one action sometimes it's four but two
to three is typical four to six is
typical for the most important pieces of
information it could be a little lesser
it could be more if you know those
things you're ready to design that view
much more effectively than if you don't
if you just dump everything on there if
you don't really understand what's
important and what's not well no wonder
you don't use size to call out what's
important you don't know what it is so
find out what it is before you get ready
to uh to design of you and go back and
talk to users if you need to about what
they need now these principles can
unfortunately be subverted this is a
concept called evil by design to induce
the users to do things that you want
them to do but not or not necessarily in
their best interest and it's highly
unethical an example is here from the
the Hilton honors app for Android when I
went to install this on my Nokia phone
this came up that their frequent stay
app wants access to my contacts why they
don't have any reason to want to talk to
my contacts and that's a particular
that's a potential security breach for
their customers they should never have
done it for the record by the way I've
correspondent with them about this and
they just don't care I mean I can show
you the the Twitter stuff back and forth
if you want the details and notice that
the stuff having to do with permissions
that you're giving them is kind of gray
background not particularly bright or
bold or easy you
notice it they don't want you to notice
it what they want you to do is click
this big green install button down here
and they make it big and green and make
it stand out to influence you to do what
they want don't do that sort of thing
it's unethical by the way they even
changed it they've made it even worse
now that way it was my first one in
nowadays when you go in they don't even
show the security stuff unless you press
a button I forget where the button is on
here somewhere and the permissions view
details there it is when you do that you
get this you get that same stuff but now
they hide it one layer deeper they're
progressively becoming more evil in
their UX design I don't stay in that
that hotel chains by the way because of
this Citibank really wants me to go
paperless
but I'm paranoid I don't open my paper
statements but I do throw them in a box
and there have been a few times in my
life where I was really glad that I had
those papers take me some box so I'm not
going paperless I know they want me to
so they put this thing up make all of
your accounts paperless and now they've
got accept and manage settings what does
that mean is that going to lead me down
the same path that there's no exit back
to unpay palace I don't know what I want
to do is go to my accounts
where's the button for that well it's up
there on the city icon so I did find a
way to get to my accounts and bypass
this screen but that's just that's just
bad that's just a not ethical it suffers
in other principles that prime or
influence what users expect we've talked
a bit about archetypes let me show you
an example I was in a hotel in
Pennsylvania and I'm going to get on the
Internet so yeah I just want free
internet do some browsing so I see the
thing high-speed internet and I press it
I don't get nothing why because it's not
a button
when I scroll down and see the whole
screen it looks like this don't make
things in your UI that look like buttons
but aren't buttons I mean if the
elevator example didn't already convince
you I hope this does and I see this more
commonly than you would think people put
headers and they look like buttons don't
do that I mean that's a button but it
looks exactly the same as that except
for a little bit of margin and now we've
seen that example meant to remove that
slide from there when you use colored
you do need to be aware though that
users don't actually see color the way
you think that they do for example if I
mask out a bunch of things here and get
down to there see those two balls were
actually the same color it's just that
your eyes aren't tuned to that because
you see color in relation to other color
let me show you my own my my little app
for that
oops no it's wrong wrong one and that's
it so let's take a look at this that bar
going through the middle is all the same
color it's monochrome your eye however
does not perceive it that way because
your eye perceives color in relation to
the colors around it that was necessary
in we were out worrying about leopards
and such you want to be able to see that
the leopard is a leopard whether it's in
sunshine or whether it's in shade so
your eyes are evolved to be able to
automatically adjust to varying
conditions and see things in relation to
the other things around that thing to
show you here I've got I got this guy's
draggable so I can drag him okay I'm
just gonna drag it I'll put in here I'm
gonna drag him along the thing and
you'll see and I promise you I'm not
changing the color of him as I move him
he's just gray
and that works in any any color works in
blue same sorry the the optical illusion
that kicked a lot of this off done by
the researchers is this one who's seen
this yeah you didn't believe it did you
that a and B are actually the same color
here I'll show you you can mask it out
and do it like I did with one of the
other ones but I wrote a program to let
me drag I did a little extract of the B
so I can drag now watch carefully now
there's B there's B there's B there's B
until he gets into here and then I'm
gonna put him in here and then when he
gets to here he just fits right in
so under understand use you want to use
gradients because they feel natural to
the user in many cases pure monochrome
feels artificial but be careful about
using colors that you don't get into
trouble with people misinterpreting them
how much time do I got left about five
minutes something like that oh no I've
got less than that dying I better get I
better get going then because I've got a
lot of a lot of interesting stuff I'd
like to show you if I can I'm gonna skip
this part then it's in something a
little bit and get down to effective use
of color keep your keep your overall
theme subtle because you want things
when you do use color for signaling you
want it to stand out don't make things
too bright even even for signaling I
never use genuine red for any hardly
anything I use instead a color called
light salmon which is kind of a reddish
orangish color and communicates very
well but isn't so fatiguing to look at
use subtle gradients I mention that
check your culture in China good is
actually signal with red and delegate
this to visual specialist
you can they're pretty good at it other
factors combined with color to affect
meaning for example smoothness connotes
safety sharp edges connote danger that's
called the contour bias principle I can
prove this to you in the following sense
that that that kind of information the
sharpness etc is more important than
words in some situations you need to be
convinced you could send this to you
know your significant other and not a
beautiful font you'll always be my
Valentine but if you do nothing but
change the shapes now the the perceived
meaning is dramatically different yeah
am I out of town now I was going to talk
about color blindness but I think I'm
out of time
somebody can somebody tipped me off on
that officially yeah well then I will
officially stop because I don't like to
it's it's lunch time oh do you want to
stay for a few more minutes in it being
lunch time okay well great then we'll do
a few more minutes thank you for
indulging me that anybody that leaves I
won't feel bad about it you may be
hungry at this point colorblindness
it doesn't mean a person you can't see
color it means certain pairs of colors
they find it hard to tell the difference
and it's only less around 5% of the
typical user population primarily male
red-green color blindness is the most
common if you take care of that you're
down to a small fraction of 1% of people
who are going to struggle and the most
common way to deal with colorblindness
in your apps is to have things I have a
colorblind theme that's what we normally
do these days dark theme light theme
colorblind theme would typically be the
three themes themes that you would want
to implement so red-green colorblind
users it's not just red-green they have
its various shades of red from various
shades of green they also can't tell
dark red from black very well
blue from purple or like it turns out
light green from white is is a struggle
so what you do typically if you've got
something like this and you really don't
know how that's going to to come across
to colorblind people there are actually
apps and you can paste a bitmap
screenshot of your app into this app and
it will kill it will show you what a
colorblind person is going to precede it
but you can do a quick and dirty way of
doing that just by applying a grayscale
filter and in this case you can see the
great kind of fades away and you don't
see it anymore
whereas the orange still stands out
pretty well so it's not just color it's
also hue that matter to accommodate
colorblind people vary by saturation and
brightness as well as color and try to
lean on shapes as well as color you
don't have to just use color for
signaling ideally you would use shapes
as well and so that means that the
colorblind folks are going to have some
information to pick up on my general
principle here is you should design so
that the 95% of people who aren't
colorblind have a great experience and
the colorblind people have a good
experience they simply can't perceive
all the things you put into the app
otherwise but you want to accommodate
them by but by taking these principles
into account there are as I said there
are software simulators there but don't
handicap the 95 percent do all kinds of
variations I start just a bit about
mental mapping and I will let you go to
lunch I talked about it a little bit
before but it's very important that I
don't see used as often in software as I
think it should be I'm going to
illustrate by by showing a couple of
examples from my life of the gas range I
used for eight years back in the 80s and
early 90s and the gas range I've used
for the last 26 years the one that I
used for eight years back in the 80s I
never turned on the wrong burner not a
single time the one I have now is gonna
be the one there on the left I turned on
a wrong burner about two months ago
I'd do it up several times a year what
the difference between these ranges this
is what the buttons look like on the
range I have today there are labels of
course which of course I don't read most
of the time this is what the buttons
look the knobs look like on the range I
used to have and I wish I had it back
even though it was manufactured in the
50s notice the perspective of the
burners matches the arrangement of the
knobs so that's an example of mental map
the mapping principle mental mapping of
a control surface to what's going on in
the real world here's another one I took
this in my hotel room just down the
street you've got big flush small flush
so what did what do the control things
look like they're big and they're small
it's amazing to me that most developers
don't even think about making buttons
different sizes to communicate something
about what they do in the real world
this has no labels when I'm up in city
like London with international visitors
labels who would not be desirable would
not be the best way to do it
so how would you like to look at
information well let's suppose we've got
some I don't know customer interaction
information there's the datagrid way
there's the more modern at kind of thing
you might put on your smartphone that's
not too bad but what if we put it on
timeline that we know when the thing
happened roughly by mapping on a
timeline that's another example of
mental mapping people automatically do
it we also get some leverage of the
proximity principle because things that
happen too close together are grouped
close together and therefore it's
they're probably related in some fashion
we're going to okay all right well
that's fortunately I had an example from
Dropbox but that was my last one so I
will put on the last slide and you folks
can go have some lunch oh there is see
they deceived me I said I could go on
I'm sorry whoever the presenter is next
time I beg your pardon I will get out
right now thank you very much folks
you're welcome to go and talk to me as I
shared tear down a few with